eine Kleinstadt in Bayern sucht nach
einem Killer dem Disco Killer vom
Eiskeller der Tatort in ist aschgau im
Chiemgau 20 Minuten von Rosenheim
entfernt und der Eiskeller das ist dort
der beliebteste Musikclub und jetzt der
Schauplatz eines gruseligen Mordfalls
ihr Blick geht zu Boden die linke Hand
ist leicht geballt es ist das letzte
Foto das Hannah W aus Aschau im Chiemgau
zeigt
12 Stunden nach der Aufnahme ziehen
Feuerwehrleute ihre Leiche aus der Prien
die Studentin wurde ermordet und in den
Fluss geworfen jetzt sucht die
40-köpfige soko-club der Kripo Rosenheim
nach dem Killer der Studentin
[Musik]
in der Nacht zum Montag war Hanna W im
Musikclub Eiskeller die Kamera am
Ausgang zeigt wie Sie den Club gegen
2:30 Uhr allein verlässt die Ermittler
vermuten dass sie nach Hause laufen
wollte ihr Elternhaus ist ca 10 Minuten
entfernt ein Nachbar zu Bild eigentlich
wollt ihr ein bekannt dass sie abholen
doch als sie am Eiskeller eintraf war
sie schon weg wahrscheinlich hatte der
Täter der Studentin vor der Disco
aufgelauert denn er floss in dem sie
später gefunden wurde liegt in der
entgegengesetzten Richtung der Fundort
scheint nicht der Tatort zu sein sagt
ein Polizeisprecher die Ermittler gehen
davon aus dass der Körper bis zu 10 km
weit im wassertrieb bevor er von einer
Wurzel gestoppt wurde eine erste
Obduktion ergab dass Hanna weh durch
Gewalteinwirkung starb ihr Körper wie es
zudem weitere Wunden auf die etwa von
Treibgut im Wasser verursacht worden
sein könnten der Fall erinnert an das
tragische Schicksal von Veronika R denn
vor vier Jahren wird die 23-jährige
Studentin nach einem Clubbesuch im
schneller angefahren kommt unter bislang
ungeklärten Umständen zu Tode die
Parallelen zum Fall Hanna W fallen auf
beide Frauen sind 23 Jahre alt beide
Frauen arbeiten in Tourismusbetrieben in
der Region beide Frauen kommen nach
einem Besuch der Disco Eiskeller zu Tode
Gibt es ein zusammenhang ist
möglicherweise derselbe Täter
verantwortlich
[Musik]